Real concern,
a few things came together.
One is that I spent a lot of time
looking at the environmental trends and
conditions.
This is something that you can do in an
academic environment.
You have time to reflect,
and I've been in this field since 1970
and I thought I'd look back and see how
we were doing and what I found was that
we're really a,
despite his growing strengthen
environmental community,
the growing sophistication,
the growing number of groups here,
we find ourselves 40 years later on the
verge of losing the planet,
uh,
have really ruining this place for our
children and grandchildren,
but the data point in the wrong
directions.
So that was one thing.
The other conclusion that I came to,
part of that really is that the way
we're going about environmentalism in
our country today is not going to
suffice.
We could double the efforts of the types
of things that we do now in mainstream
environmental racism.
And it would improve things marginally,
but it would not carry the day would not
win where we need to win.